我是今年是36岁，
然后是体制内年收入20万这样子在广西的收入，
我是一个未婚的，
然后现在感觉有一点点迷茫，
我先跟你说，
因为我的原生家庭吧，
就是我有两个姐姐呀，
然后有两个哥哥，
我妈从小的时候就不在啊，
我爸爸现在应该准备80了，
然后跟着我哥哥，
从小呢，
从初中就是我那个二姐夫是供的读书，
然后大学毕业，
然后在体制内工作，
在我们那里的市里面买了一套房，
也是翻配房，
然后装修没多久我就去买南宁了，
就疫情的时候嘛，
因为你来的是我姐夫，
相当于就是再生父母这种感觉了，
疫情的时候，
因为他是做生意的嘛。
就是房地产这一块吧，
我那边卖疫情有5000万没有下来，
然后当时他们急用钱的时候，
我就贷款了蛮多的，
应该有六七十万吧，
然后就借给他们，
所以我现在是属于一个负债的情况，
现在我也有一点点迷茫，
对自己的人生规划，
以前刚毕业出来呢，
他那里面的也有很多人追，
一直都有人追，
但是就感觉谈了谈了两三个还是不成，
就有点你今年多大了，
姑娘36岁，
但是可人看起来人家总是觉得我是觉得有点大大咧咧，
然后又有点就是没心没肺的那种嘛，
那你自己很优秀啊，
你自己在体制内年薪有20万，
你自己是很优秀的呀，
呃，
看着又显年轻是吧，
有的时候就是我真实年龄是多大，
这个事儿放一边，
就是我看起来像多大很关键，
嗯，
就是平时在别人面前表现的时候，
人家就问他说你是哪一年的，
我都不好意思说，
我就说你猜都以为是，
反正就是跟实际的年龄不太相符的那些嘛，
在。
遇到你最想要解决的问题是什么？
你最大的困惑是什么呢？
我最大的困惑就是我现在负债也负债，
慢慢的跟那些人协商，
然后慢慢的还债，
然后还有一个问题就是我想现在年纪也大了，
然后也一直有人追我，
也尝试着去接接触，
就是不成，
我也不懂为什么。
嗯，
就是不成，
主要是比如说是别人要断崖式分手，
还是你这边主动就分手了，
就比如说我们两个发生了一些矛盾，
然后生产，
我就会觉得很痛苦，
然后我就想分他，
他觉得没有那么大的包容性，
每一次都是你主动要提分开是吗？
嗯嗯。
那现在还是有很多人追求你是么？
也有，
但是我觉得都是烂桃花啊，
那你希望龙丽姐帮你解答的问题是什么呢？
就想你能不能给一些人生建议，
就是说接下来我应该怎么办比较好？
这是关于负债这个问题，
如果我把市区里面的那一套房子给卖了，
然后基本上是可以上岸了，
那欠的主要是银行的钱啊，
网贷公司的钱，
还是欠的是朋友亲戚的钱，
就是银行的还有网贷的一些，
总共加起来欠多少？
六七十吧，
如果我把就是市里面的房子给卖的话，
应该到手可以50万，
剩下20万的话，
因为房产证还没有到手，
这20万对我来说应该不是什么问题，
如果你认为背负这样的债，
成为你心里面最大的一块石头，
那我觉得是可以卖掉房子把债还掉的，
就把下面的那个石头搬开，
然后你才能看到自己的心里装了些什么，
心里的欲望是什么，
心里想要追求的生活是什么，
这个啊，
这个然长大了以后发现每个人活着都不容易，
尤其是在你的直播间看到了这些啊，
你现在这个困境啊，
你自己还能解套的，
你卖掉那套房子了之后，
你把债务还完了之后，
你现在来看自己，
你有健康的身体，
有一个很好的工作，
非常稳定你。
收入20万已经超越了99%的女性啊，
年纪也不算太大，
就是三十几岁也不算太大，
你追求自己想要的样了，
幸福的状态的话，
现在你这个基础条件都还在的，
心里不要给自己太大的压力哦，
那你还完债了，
你没有负债的情况下的话，
那你现在的条件摆在这里，
你找对象的话是很好找的，
在众多追求你的人当中的话，
我们不断的去接触嘛，
就是哪怕是哎这边拔将军啊，
大家可以拔一个以前在。
我们市里面的时候都后刚毕业出来，
20多岁嘛，
然后追的人也挺多，
但是老是挑三拣四的，
也错过了挺多人，
就是就是心里面先接纳自己，
先接纳自己，
哦，
我就是36岁了，
呃，
不要说老说外表上看起来我多大年纪啊，
不要去欺骗自己，
我内心深处先接纳我自己，
我就是三六岁了，
我有一份稳定的工作，
我年薪20万，
我现在想找一个什么样的男生，
如我认为我找一个离过婚的，
年龄比我稍微大一点的，
比如他40岁，
他离过婚了，
小孩更前妻，
或者没有小孩儿，
我觉得我能接受的话，
好，
我就不要在意外界怎么看，
不要在意同事怎么看，
不要在意亲戚怎么看我怎么看，
我心里能接受吗？
受，
那我就照着这个方向去找，
就是这年头的好男人，
他并不流通，
无非是一方犯错误，
也不一定，
我跟你讲人跟人，
他就是要讲缘分的，
有的人他两个人本身很好的人，
很善良的人，
或者说呃，
两个人都很上进，
很努力，
但他俩凑一块儿的话，
就是矛盾很多，
不一块儿的话就是过不下去日子，
真有这样的。
我不骗你们，
你们现实生活中应该也看到吧，
就是男的脾气也挺好的呀，
女的人也挺好的呀，
他俩在一起就天天打，
天天吵，
不是不合适，
他俩可能就是刚开始的时候相互吸引，
到最后的话就是相互像刺猬一样相互排斥，
但他俩本人都没有什么大毛病，
所有的这些市面上的这些毒鸡汤，
你都不要把它奉为龟臬，
所有的那种一肝散单一传人的那种说法，
他都是违背哲学根基了，
所有的哲学根基就是有原则就有例外，
好男人在市面上不流通的就离了婚的都不是好男人吗？
离了婚的都不是好女人吗？
这种说法都是非常非常狭隘的。
是不是我也想这两年就是可能那年底的时候房产证下来，
把它那个房子一卖，
然后估计也就，
而且我认为你的这个事情是冤有头债有主，
因为我觉得我姐书然后当做是自己的女儿一样，
你看读书从初中开始读书到大学，
都是我姐一直给钱给我，
然后买房子的时候，
他们也给了一点首付，
车子也是他们给的，
所以我觉得我把这些钱借给他们也是理所应该的，
那他们总得还吧，
他们肯定是要还的呀，
也可以直就是现在这个个债务在我身上压的好重啊，
然后前几年一直盼着他的钱下来，
然后一直又没下来，
现在我就开始慢慢的捋，
我就觉得有点错过了好几年还蛋的时间了，
而且都是大手大脚的，
怎吧，
先把你压在心头的石头，
你认为它是最大的那块石头，
先把它搬开啊，
先做这个还款的计划，
嗯。
好，
对吧，
关于婚姻这一块，
有时候我觉得看见，
就比如说今年我身边已经有5对离婚了，
我就觉得有时候好像不结婚也可以，
然后自己感觉自己过日子，
你说自己想吧，
嗯，
其实这个事情啊，
如果你自己内心足够强大，
你能够抵御外界的那些压力，
比如说来自亲人啊，
来自同事啊，
你能够抵御这些东西的话，
其实这也是一条可选择的路。
呃，
怕就怕你内心不够强大，
一方面自己会想，
一方面自己想一个人过，
另一方面你又没有那么足够强大的内心去抵御外界给你的这些压力，
你我不是经常问他说，
哎，
我觉得你很不错啊，
为什么刚还没有结婚生孩子把出了这些不是我不懂，
我也不是很把所有的东西，
就是关于负债啊，
这些东西也刚都跟人家说，
我也不想跟别人说太多。
啊，
你不想跟别人说太多的话，
就先把这个负债的问题先抓紧时间解决掉，
所以说结婚选对象这个事情的话，
我们报以最大的诚意去做这个事情，
报以最大的诚意去跟别人去接触，
如果说实在哎没碰到合适的，
实在没有碰到你想要跟他步入婚姻的，
也完全的接纳自己，
那就是不难当我觉得这些东西，
嗯，
好，
那就这样啊，
必是不能圆满，
你那信会不会这嗯，
拜拜你就是这是一个非常客观的数据，
就是我们从现有的数据来看的话，
大概约等于40%的人是要去领四个证儿的，
领两个证是吧，
开开心心的领回家，
然后再领两个证，
加起来有四个证，
40%的人都会走这条路，
这是一个数据，
谁都逃不掉，
我跟大家讲一下，
我自己的心态好不好，
我自己的心态就是我跟任何一个人谈恋爱的时候，
我都报以了最大的这种真诚，
奔着好好过日子去谈这个恋爱，
但是我没有办法左右结果，
我心里是知道的，
我可能跟任何一任。
伴侣不一定能走到最后啊，
因为也许我很爱他，
我很愿意跟他在一起，
但是或许人家也容忍了我很久，
或许人家也不喜欢跟我在一起生活，
这些东西都是我无法强求的，
因为我也确实谈了好几段恋爱啊，
就是就是。
分分合合了之后，
现在再看这个问题的话，
就人是会非常淡然，
什么叫非常然呢？
就是我很真诚的付出我的真心来跟你好好的过日子，
如果有一天啊，
我不想过了，
或者你不想过了，
我也能够坦然的接受这样的结局。
最起码我们曾经在一起过日子的那些点点滴滴是真实的，
它存在在我的生命里，
我曾经因为你出现在我的生命里，
我感受过喜乐，
感过温暖，
感受过被爱，
我觉得这个就很够了，
生命不就是这样吗？
曾经你出现在我的生命里，
确实给我带来了那么多的呃，
快乐啊，
那么多的这个美好的时光，
这个就很够了。
我现在大概就是这样的一个逻辑，
你要问我说我跟现在的这个伴侣就一定能够白头偕老吗？
我首先摆明我自己的态度啊，
从我的这个角度来说的话，
我觉得他挺好啊，
我愿意跟他白头到老啊，
但是人家未必愿意跟我白头到老啊，
姐妹们，
咱要勇敢的接纳这个现实，
我反正我能接受，
他如果不愿意跟我白头到老的话啊，
从我的这个角度来说的话，
那是你的损失啊，
我也不会强求啊，
女人就得有点姐的那个自信，
我喜欢你是你的荣幸，
你喜欢我是我的魅力啊，
我现在跟姐天天恨不得拿笔记本，
拿笔记本学习。